Yeah.
Welcome to reckless disagreement.
The only show on the Internet
that you can trust. I'm your host,
a paranoid recluse. And here's a
clip from Raiders of the lost Ark.
Yeah.
Now,
when I saw that scene as a kid,
I just assumed that that's how grown ups
got drunk after they made me go to bed.
But when I grew up and
started drinking on my own,
I realized that if you tried to play a
drinking game like that, you would die.
I'm meticulous.
Research tells me that it takes 30
minutes to feel the effects of alcohol.
So if you're taking shots up until the
second that you collapse on the floor,
you're going to keep getting more drunk.
So this sweaty fat man isn't just
passing out, is falling into a coma.
Marian Ravenwood just killed that
guy
and then she killed that guy.
This made me realize no one who makes
movies has ever been drunk somehow.
So I decided that I would get drunk
and explained to them all the mistakes
they're making. All right, let's see. Uh,
that's not right. They're supposed to be,
oh, there's a title. Aw, it's gorgeous.
And I love it.
Raiders isn't the only movie that thinks
this is how drinking games work and the
two towers legless and Gimley engaged in
a drinking game with only three rules.
So it's a drinking.
No,
that's just drinking game implies
like ping pong balls or underwear,
right?
This is the only drinking game.
Anyone in movies ever replays
and even happens in four
we fought, he made his ancestors
proud. I admit I'm not a viking,
but how does drinking so much that
your buddy has to carry you home,
make anybody proud of you?
This game only makes sense
if your perspective on
drinking is limited to sing.
People leave for and returned from the
bar and you're just trying to guess what
went on in between to turn your
friends into pukey bags of shame. Well,
you guessed wrong movies,
you guessed real wrong,
and you should be ashamed
in movies,
bars,
the place you go when you're just
itching for an excuse to explode into a
whirlwind of gritty fisticuffs.
There's so many examples that I'm
just going to stick to movies.
I love like the guests,
dirty work,
Deadpool,
and I'd be kind of an idiot if I
didn't at least mention roadhouse.
Okay.
Now show me another clip from dirty
work. Oh, nice. Stone Street bike, man.
You just hit g eight.
Yeah,
if you like,
now I'm getting here. Rock bar fights
happen and they're always hilarious.
But your average dive bar isn't the time
bomb of homophobia waiting to be set
off by a guy with dreamy eyes
ordering a blowjob shot at the blue.
Not every bar fight I've ever seen.
It was just a couple of drunk dudes
grappling with each other and spelling my
drink and to the bouncer kicked it off.
And you know what to all the people
writing comments about how bad ass the bar
fights you've been in are, who are
you trying to impress is in me? Oh,
I'm flooding. Keep uh, keep,
uh, yeah, keep doing that.
Okay.
So we'll just afford to drinks on me.
I am completely sure that nothing like
that has ever happened in all of history.
I've worked in a bar and I don't even
know how you'd do that as a bartender.
Nothing important. Wait, as the
guy who offered to buy the rounds,
not paying for the beer,
what I might be wrong about this.
I mean when I worked in a bar,
I was 17 and the bartender and used to
give me a six pack. When I did a good job,
nothing's going to shut down.
The effects might be related,
but they also make me question
this scene from Skyfall,
it was just happened. Did bond walk
in there with a Scorpion and say, hey,
everyone watched this or does a bartender
habit waiting there would have anybody
who isn't James Bond order's this cocktail
like say a drunk me and get stung and
dies. Is the reputation for being the bar
with the Scorpions worth the hassle of
disposing of dead bodies and the
effort it takes to feed and maintain a
terrarium of deadly Arachnids?
No, no. It's not. Next entry
movies think beer makes you hallucinate.
[inaudible]
not to Brag,
but I've been really drunk before.
I've gone on journeys of inebriated
self discovery and I feed on cop cars,
but I've never been so drunk that I
hallucinated something that wasn't there
because alcohol's effect
is the opposite of that.
I'm pretty sure this joke comes
from the scene and Pinocchio,
Pinocchio sees all his friends turning
into donkeys and he slowly pushes away
his glass of beer because he just
figured out that that'll turn him into a
donkey to,
but everyone in Hollywood assume that
Pinocchio thought the beer was making him
hallucinate because they've never
been drunk before. So let me be clear,
Hollywood, if you want to
see things that aren't there,
you're going to have to do what the
rest of us do and go make friends with
someone with a snake tattoo. But if
movie booze isn't helping you trip out,
it's giving you special powers and the
Big Bang theory, which none of you watch.
But all of you know about a character
named Raj can only talk to women when he's
drunk. Then he can talk to him. Fine.
Like a normy. Well, the red a simulation,
that's not a wacky joke about shyness.
That's a serious drinking,
kind of like what Tom Cruise has in
the last Samurai until the Samurai.
Just like take his booze away for a couple
of days and he wakes up cure not just
of his addiction but also of pts.
Ah,
how peaceful the nature,
the trees,
their sobriety.
Japan has cured me.
I am so good at being Japanese.
I am the Last Samurai IRS my kidneys.
Okay.
All right. Uh, well all
the lights were out there.
Someone just informed me that
lots of people drink and uh,
my thesis is ridiculous. Fine. Thanks
Kevin. And I mentioned that earlier,
but uh,
even so let's take stock of how
Hollywood drinks first they chuck,
then they fight.
Then the inconvenience of bartender and
then the Scorpion that might not even be
there before quitting drinking forever
and move into Japan. That's not healthy.
That's an unsustainable way to live.
You got to sort this out in movies.
That's what I'm really, well sure. Roles.
But in the top of the
way to end it though,
I guess let's try,
Hey, you like stand up, come
see the cracked standup show.
It's happening June 22nd at
meltdown comics in Los Angeles.
If you want to see amazing
comics, including our own
Josh sergeant, go to Nerd,
melt la.com/tickets and if you
want to see me do a funny dance.
Sorry,
not today.